[Music]
before careers in politics many American
presidents found success outside of
Washington Warren Harding struck gold
publishing newspapers Herbert Hoover an
affluent minor the bush is wildly
successful in the oil business Donald
Trump you know real estate these men
were industry Pioneers until Duty called
Joe Biden's different this president has
revolutionized whole industry from the
White House in just three years Biden's
made himself the world's most successful
travel agent business is booming so much
that his travel agency is losing track
of
orders how many people has this
Administration let in by encountering
processing dispersing or that have come
in as a known or or unknown goway what
approximately I don't need an exact
number so what do we got Senor let me
let me let me say I need numbers I again
don't F bust me how many people has this
administration led into the country let
me say at the outset that uh our job
would be a lot easier if the broken
immigration system was Mr secretary I
want a number how many people have you
led into this country I I should also
okay I I'll give you the number it's
about six million riding the hottest
travel Market in history Joe Biden is to
the travel industry what Steve Jobs was
to computers Henry Boards of cars
migrants from all over the world are not
only camping outside our border like a
midnight sneaker release but they're
packing a full
itinerary how you doing where you from
Sagal Sagal where you going New York
where you from Sagal where you going
North Carolina where you from from Sagal
where you going uh Columbus do you Sagal
where are you going Los Angeles oh smart
man Joe Biden oh what do you say to Joe
Biden Joe Biden is the
the American president you like him yeah
yeah okay Jo bid is good you Joe Biden's
good yeah or not Trump no no no
no we thought TSA pre-check was a
GameChanger America's Chief travel agent
Joe Biden is transforming international
travel as we know it never before has
international travel been so easy at the
tap of an app thousands of foreign
Nationals can be fied in from anywhere
in the world right into our country
courtesy of Biden you can now make an
appointment to break into the country
Biden's travel agents don't like to brag
they let the numbers do the
talking congresswoman the border is
secure and the border is not open the
entire hemisphere is suffering a
migration crisis we are seeing an
unprecedented movement of people from
country to Country it is not restricted
to the southern border our approach to
managing the borders securely and mainly
even within our fundamentally broken
immigration system is working it's not
just the number one app in Latin America
Biden's open table for illegals is a hit
in the midd East too Iran Lebanon Syria
Iraq and Afghanistan all love the app is
there any heartburn around here 600,000
known Goda ways just in the last fiscal
year yeah is it possible that somebody
who wants to commit a terrorist attack
during a time of elevated threat cross
the Sou border into the United States
already I I couldn't possibly answer
that question Peter almost 8,000
migrants that we consider known and
suspected terrorists have used Biden's
travel app to enter the country it's
like clear for terrorists at the same
time Iranians are firing rockets at our
military bases Biden's shuttling them
into the country Biden doesn't care what
you look like as long as your money's
green and every Savvy businessman knows
you need to create demand for your
product Biden's travel agency motto is
fast streamlined processing and
successful
resettling those are the phrases they
use to ask Congress for money now
remember these aren't foreigners these
are future
customers we checked Biden's travel app
and it has five stars throughout the
third world here's the head of a caravan
raving about how great a travel agent
Joe Biden is Joe Biden Administration
has uh has lost the ball had lost the
power and and America
has has not been paying attention what's
happening Mexico is being uh use usually
ganging up with all the countries to
make sure that all this immigration goes
straight into the United States and and
that's that's what it is every country
has been just providing their rights
charging them 20 30 or $40 and then just
pushing them in pushing them in all the
way to the Mexican borders where's the
American intelligence don't they know
that the all the countries are
conspiring against the United States to
make sure they have this crisis but
Biden's a full service travel agency
he'll take care of multiple legs of the
trip travel agent Biden all you can fly
voucher unlimited miles is just what you
need Board of Texas Biden and Kamala
will fly to New York in the middle of
the night afraid of flying free bus
tickets Pete Buddha jedge will pick you
up and take you right to your hotel I'm
sorry ombre Martha's Vineyards all
booked up for the year how does Florida
sound don't you worry your foreign
little head hotel accommodations of
course are taken care of have about a
room in the heart of Midtown theater
district I think Hamilton's still
playing looks like we have a room for
you at the Roosevelt would you like us
to upgrade you to the penthouse binder
here will gladly check you in and our
bellhop mayorcas will of course help
with your bags oh
Alejandro bags to room 405 Pronto for
the affordable fees of0 dollar the Biden
travel agency will gladly comp their
meals too they've gotten some feedback
about American food we hear you only
culturally appropriate meals from now on
and you look like the senator from
Pennsylvania come here Eric Adams will
do your laundry that's right he's
handing out million dooll contracts to
laundry companies to you know help the
migrants stay fresh and are you a
dreamer perhaps well we'll pay for your
college just like Americans you too can
learn about how racist white people are
and I can see you little foreign
snowbirds getting anxious as the weather
drops you're probably not used to this
climate we get it we like to leave New
York too the Democrats have you covered
one-way tickets out of New York are
being offered you can fly to San
Francisco for free where Nome will cater
to your every whim you can even carjack
someone he won't call ICE even better
identify as a black transwoman because
you're entitled to free money mucho Dao
there's also Sanctuary cities who will
gladly welcome you if you like the sound
of that how about I book you into
Chicago we have a beautiful cot for you
at the airport the police station or the
elementary school and here's two tickets
to the Bears game on us they need to
fill
seats the only compliment about Biden's
travel agency is that they can't get
enough customers here fast enough St
Louis is begging for more migrants I
mean
customers St Louis says they need more
foreigners because Americans aren't
having enough babies I didn't say that
that's what St Louis is saying do we
have enough money to pay for this what a
silly question we'll just defund the
police and where's gotten out you can
see Caravans marching from Miles and
Miles I'm sorry the Biden travel agency
has raised expectations anything less
than Cradle to the Grave welfare
unacceptable
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else